but let's do this now that we got you
know most people here let's talk right
right now about what's going on in
Atlanta because the governor Kemp has
declared a state of emergency and
they're gonna be deploying 1000 are
troops ma the media is refusing I'm
sorry this is just the way I see it the
media is refusing to address what's
really happening in Atlanta at the
Wendy's where Rashard Brooks died there
is a sustained and ongoing black lives
matter presence yeah a little girl was
killed a when old 8 years old when these
armed groups guarding a parking lot
across the street from the Wendy's
opened fire and I believe was an SUV
shoot his little girl the father gave us
gave a speech where he said you say
black he says you say black lives matter
but you killed your own you killed a
little girl why isn't the media saying
black lives matter activists protesters
whatever word they want to use kill
little girl why is every story like
senseless violence little girl shot yet
if I guarantee you if you had one guy
out there wearing a trump hat they would
have been like far-right extremist
extremists execute child I mean this has
been going on it happened in in chop
chazz chazz whatever you want to call it
it's like a bunch of people were killed
and it's like the the dad of the the one
of the guys that got killed out there
was like what in the net what is going
on
you know why the the mayor's not calling
me but Trump called me president of the
United States called me to say that it's
a terrible thing that happened to you
and I'm just like how is the mayor not
because the mayor knows that kids blood
is on the mayor's hands look at aunt and
the governor both of them let me show
this real quick just so I can make sure
you'll have the context this is from NPR
Georgia Georgia Governor Brian Kemp is
activating up to 1000 National Guard
troops after a spate of shootings and
protests in Atlanta over the weekend
five people died including an
eight-year-old girl and at least thirty
people were injured the Republican
governor issued an executive order
Monday that would send the National
Guard to protect the State Capitol the
governor's mansion and the Department of
Public Safety headquarters where close
to 100 demonstrators set fire to part of
the building early Sunday morning
amazing now this is this is a Republican
governor he could have done something
sooner
I suppose he waited until the last
minute which is not good because our
little girl has died but take a look at
the mayor
Lanna take a look at the mayor of
Seattle and what do we have a lot of
people see the media is not giving the
same attention to Atlanta in this
Wendy's but it was occupied very
similarly to what we saw in the Chazz
they didn't make a public declaration
though but there have been armed groups
mind you sidestep
your you can legally bear arms in this
country and walk around in guard places
but at a certain point when people keep
getting shot the police need to do
something what did they do the mayor the
DA attacked the police after the race
shot Brookes killing putting this this
cop facing of charging him with felony
murder because a guy stole his weapon
knocked his friend down his his partner
down ran and then turned and fired the
weapon at him that cop for defending
himself is facing felony murder matters
now the police are demoralized far-left
groups and black lives matter groups are
occupying the area to varying degrees
multiple people have been shot two days
ago a little girl gets shot
the next day three people get shot a 53
year old man is killed and now now
they're like maybe we should come in and
do something about this it's and bring
us back to what you were saying about
Seattle yeah the mayor said we're gonna
we could maybe have a summer of love
it's it's like a festival and then when
a 16 year old and a 14 year old and
they're both young black men are driving
an SUV according to multiple reports
they were joyriding they had stolen a
vehicle one witness said she was on the
phone with them and she told them to go
to the Chas for safety and then the
security for some reason unloaded some
witnesses one witness reported sent
reportedly said three hundred-plus
rounds and ten minutes of sustained fire
on this vehicle and in the livestream of
what happened you can only hear they
walk up to the vehicle and you hear a
guy say oh you're still alive and then
something about pistol-whipping him yeah
some people are trying to have argued
that he then executed the 60 year old
finishing him off I don't know if that's
true what I do know is the mayor still
did nothing you do hear a shot I watched
that video and then you hear the shot
you can hear a shot fired after he says
oh you're still alive what if I pistol
whip you and then you hear a shot bang
and it's just like what do you Shanna
and you know what the one thing that
made the mayor react was when they
showed up at her house yeah and so did
she call the father of the nine
ten year old who died no definitely not
trumped absolutely not and he did prawns
so so this is the uphill battle man yeah
that we have this level of violence now
over a month the media covers it less
and less because people are desensitized
to it doesn't generate the same traffic
or interest no but it's not stopped so
when I first saw the story about the
eight-year-old girl who was killed I
couldn't find anything about exactly
what happened and the police the the the
the official reporting said that it was
near the site of these protests and that
that had exited the the highway at
University Avenue and we're trying to
pull into a parking lot at the 1200
block of Pryor Boulevard or whatever and
I'm like okay so the reason they're
saying this is because it must not have
anything to do with black lives matter
and then sure enough you know the
official release comes out it was the
parking lot across the street from
Wendy's and it was the armed group of
people occupying the area who unloaded
on this vehicle killing this little girl
yeah and I'm like why wouldn't the
journalist say that right now why does
it the headlight headline say black
lives matter group you know armed black
lives matter group kills a little girl
because they only want to push the
narrative that is what they want to push
that their narrative this is they don't
want people knowing that black lives
matter groups are killing black black
people so this is this this is a serious
problem we have right now agreed if if
one guy comes out and you remember that
guy in I don't know if you remember the
story in Portland he was a crazy you
know he wasn't left he wasn't right was
his nuts and he slashed three people on
it was the the Portland train system
okay yeah I don't member his name
remember that but he recently got
sentenced to life in prison over the
attacks it killed two of the guys I
think oh wow yeah he was it was reported
that he was yelling at women with hijab
what weren't wearing hijab okay and then
three guys intervened and he slashed
them they're like cornering him the
media reported that it was a right-wing
extremist okay you actually look at his
profile on the guide made no sense
he was like previously a Bernie
supporter he was a Balkan esteem on
tamerica broken up into different
countries like you could argue some
things about him more right some were
left but ultimately he was a crazy guy
and what does the media say far-right of
course you get a bunch of conservatives
who join the park
parlour you know it's like a different
social network and they say far-right
extremists yeah Nazis and stuff like
that it's so easy oh no here's that
here's my favorite the Boogaloo boys
yeah during all the unrest beginning of
last month some dude in a white van
opens up the side panel door shoots two
cops with a rifle killing one of them
when he gets went with it when they go
to catch him he kills another cop he
writes about killing cops
he writes boug in blood and then they
say right-wing huh and I'm like hold on
during the unrest okay for George Floyd
a guy who says kill cops like an Tifa
Brian actually does it now he's
right-wing now he's right-wing so when
blacks listen so they so here's the
thing
they can't call these black lives matter
people at the Wendy's right wing that's
true so they just say senseless violence
for our armed group on the 1200 block
instead of saying at the site of the
ongoing black lives matter protest armed
black lives matter individuals shot and
killed a little girl as well as several
other people five people died over the
last night you know and they they threw
a firebomb through the window of a
police department they don't say it or
the violence that's happening in New
York or Chicago oh the crime is just
through the roof it's crazy
Minnesota all these places they're just
the crime is skyrocketing and you know
you know you know people being executed
in broad daylight walking their daughter
man did you see that video I did I did
that makes me tear up a little bit just
you know just thinking about like that
little girl was walking with her dad
from her dad and she runs away man that
and you don't really made me mad she's
gonna grow up that upsets me a lot man
that's that's sad let me explain this to
everybody who hasn't feel really bad for
her for those are oh there's a viral
video right now there I think they're
offering a reward they're trying to
track this guy down in New York City
there's a video of this it's a man with
his four-year-old daughter she's four
right I'm not sure how old she was and
they're out there walking across the
street he stops with her and he looks
forward and a car pulls up on the left
side he starts walking across the street
and they stop and they start looking to
something and also and a gun points out
of the vehicle pop and the dad falls
down into his back and you see him
shaking and then everyone screams the
little girl runs away that's what's
happening in New York right now
this kind of stuff has been happening in
Chicago non-stop for decades Elon Musk
long time you see Elon Musk tweet about
this what he said I know I miss it IIIi
just you know it makes me hope that
people are starting to wake up to the
problems that we're having and and I do
especially in Chicago blame Democrats
for this you want you want to you want
to talk about the national level
Democrats we can have that conversation
but I grew up in Chicago Adams from
Chicago you know we this this place has
been just super majority Democrat
forever and the gun violence has only
gotten worse Elon Musk tweeted in
response to someone saying like the
bloodiest night in Chicago you know over
the past like decade or something and he
says this shows something like the moral
bankruptcy of the far left
there's no outrage over this yep
absolutely and you know what bothers me
when I when I see the high-level
polarizing conversation around what's
going on in Chicago you do get people on
the right saying no one cares about this
black lives matter doesn't care about it
if black lives mattered why wouldn't you
talk about Chicago right and then the
high profile left just doesn't talk
about it the reality is in Chicago they
do and they're constantly doing it but
the issue is the high-profile political
individuals know that this will not play
well enough for them to win power so you
have activists in Chicago I have
interviewed them who are fighting
marching and saying stop the violence in
our communities yeah and what is the
high profile left and the high profile
black lives matter do ignore it
taxes universal health care green new
deal whatever this marks of stuff is and
would get rid of Aunt Jemima oh yeah now
I'm not gonna blame them for that I just
make what it's making a but it is not
even funny but cuz that's that's what
they they're putting like a little tiny
band-aid like here you go here's a
band-aid for your wounds I don't even
know if a band-aid is the right word for
it right in the face yeah you're right
it's lap in the face yes but we've
talked about this they're not getting
rid of white mascots they're removing
diversity from our brands that's true
they're not interested in actually
fighting what they claim they're
fighting for hence I throw it back to
Frederick Douglass that one really makes
me angry exactly they don't they're not
fighting for equality no man with a
Booker T it was Booker T watch you want
me to read it yes okay so it says
there's a class of colored people who
make a business of keeping the troubles
the wrongs and the hardships of the
race before the public having learned
that they're able to make a living out
of their troubles they've grown into a
settled habit of advertising their
wrongs partly because they want sympathy
and partly because it pays some of these
people do not want the black man to lose
his grievances because they do not want
to lose their job and he's using
colorful language formerly colorful
language so what what can you look up
what year was Booker 1911 that was 1911
mm-hmm how amazing 1911 yep and I wonder
who he was referring to I really do
genuinely wonder but I've got to say you
know we're at a point now you know I
don't know if you saw this Joe Biden
said that if when we beat Donald Trump
we won't just rebuild this country we
will transform it yeah what does that
mean I don't know what are you trying to
say bud yeah I'm not I'm not excited by
that to be honest no cuz of all the the
political people that I've seen like
he's very racist and he has a very
racist many things that he had said I'm
just like I I'm I'm very political now I
I'm you know I'm not going back and
Biden I'm looking into you and you're
you're a sleaze bag yeah seriously I
don't well here's he's so racist it's
like and then people are calling me
racist just because I'm voting for Trump
and it's like do you know what Trump has
done for for minorities like he's done a
lot he has he's done a lot I there's
plenty of men and just starting to look
into it it was just like whoa he's you
know we can we can sit here all night
talking about that but it's it's besides
the point what we're talking about so
it's okay man they're spinning it Joe
Biden says he wants to transform this
country and the reason that's worrisome
to me is not because I think Joe Biden
himself is is a far leftist but that
he's seated ground in a desperate
attempt to beat Trump yep so I have to
wonder if these people are willing to go
as far as to tear down Frederick Douglas
I'm gonna say it a million times cuz
that dude was that that's that's so far
of the line yeah like we're not we don't
even a line line when they dragged us so
far the left so Joe Biden the Democrats
have become so desperate yep to defeat
Donald Trump and here's the way to
describe it I know is I'm gonna give you
the silly bit it's the one ring from
Lord of the Rings they think they could
wield the power yeah they cannot no and
so what
Joe Biden is going to bring the ring
rays upon us mm-hmm
he is going to be alike it is a gift to
the Democrats we will use it to defeat
our enemies then anti-fur goes and
destroys everything and what happens he
gives them ground yeah and then what now
you've got people advocating for tearing
down Thomas Jefferson right and you've
put me in a position ever-increasingly
where I'm like what's my compromise with
conservatives who I have marginal
disagreements with or with the far left
who wants to burn it all to the ground
and and literally they bring guillotines
to people's homes young effigy right
Jeff so I'm like oh is that Jeff Bezos
they put it in front of his house yeah
but but but but they've looked they've
gone to people's houses they went back
to the home with that st. Louis couple I
saw that they're still there they've had
to board up their house and hire cards
I'm glad they had they hired guards me
too but they will come to your house
that's the mayor of Seattle learn that
lesson the hard way yeah she thought she
could wield the power
mm-hm she thought she could and what
happened they went to her house and she
pulled that ring and she pulled off and
threw it as far as she could you know
she came in and she crushed them but it
was too late she tossed it over to New
York mob like yes but I also I also
wonder if it's actually just too late
for them like what really happened was
they tried using the One Ring yeah you
know the far-left as their advantage and
now they are being overrun by the the
evil by the the extremism they can't
stop it you know they're being changed
it's yeah well it's it's taking over and
now they've opened the door begging for
help we must defeat Trump by any means
necessary and they say we help you and
now they're taking over yeah and the
Democrats are panicked and Joe Biden is
the person saying just let me be
president and I'll give you half how
does that sound listen fat look fat I'll
give you half I don't know I don't I
don't want to know that's gonna look
like that worries me so there are a lot
of people who are talking about all
these different opportunities like for
2020 in ways to defeat this some people
are trying out what is it I can remember
who this was he was like if you want to
stop the far-left from taking over then
usually you'd want to vote for Joe Biden
it's like Joe Biden opened the door yeah
and Trump I don't think is doing enough
he's the mask that the far-left are
wearing you know they're like a monster
behind the mask of Joe Biden's face you
ever see what was it spirited away yes a
giant black mass with the with a white
that is no that is exactly what I'm
thinking yes yes very very you see the
Joe Biden and then you pull the mask
away and says gigantic demon thank you
so man now look like I've been saying
this for a while that if you take where
you can actually look at the New York
Times date I love showing this graph
where it shows the left going like this
just like boom veering off and the
Republicans are like kind of a squiggly
line leaning slide to the left and I'm
like so weird listen if I'm kind of
where Obama was in o8 mm-hmm in terms of
policy ideas that's fairly in the middle
compared to where most Americans
probably are we don't change that much
you know if I if I'm standing here and I
look to my right what do I see I see
Trump and a bunch of Trump supporters
waving little American flags and I'm
like I'm familiar with what that is yeah
I've lived with these people I've gone
to church with these people as a kid I'm
no longer religious but they're part of
my community I know them man do they
sometimes get on my nerves
I look to my left I don't see anything
so I climb up on a ladder I take my
binoculars out and they're all the way
off in the distance yeah are a bunch of
people burning things to the ground
surprisingly to actually see them still
right well you gotta go away and so the
analogy comes to this if I do make a
compromise I can take a few steps to to
the right as a moderate liberal you know
growing up and say listen I'm gonna give
ground on these issues if you help me
stop these crazy people who are coming
to burn everything everything everything
to the ground mm-hmm or you can go to
Biden who says walk a couple hundred
miles with me to meet these other people
and see what they're all about and I'm
like can you walk though what a minute
little electric scooters yeah
zip on over but if but if they're
tearing down statues of our heroes
mm-hmm and their allies and media are
lying to smear Trump that says something
really that that's that's even more
worrying when when Biden comes out and
says he wants to transform this country
because we know they're lying to us
absolutely Trump's not the most honest
person in the world but he's honest in
weird ways yep the intercepts wrote
about this
hey Trump they said he's the most honest
president in American history Wow
because he blurts out he's like he says
the quiet part loud and loud part quiet
yeah there are a lot of dumb things
Trump has lied about I've done a ton of
videos on this I know people I was like
what what it's like stupid things like
personal things it's like you know I
can't think of anything on top of my
head so yeah I'm gonna be put on the
spot for that well so obviously it's not
newsworthy if you can't even remember it
and you you are inundated with news and
you is if you should know if all the
people in this room you would know and
the fact that you're you know coming at
a loss to it it's like that big of a
deal they exist Obama lied to sure all
the administration's have lied the
specific thing that I owe everybody I
tip my tongue is like it was some really
weird thing he lied about that was like
a personal issue that was like why would
he lie about that okay you know and then
there's like something right now where
they said why did Kristi Noem fly on Air
Force One and Caylee McKenna D said ask
the Secret Service but the Secret
Service doesn't actually don't have
anything to do with it
there's things like that okay I
ultimately don't really care about it's
like a gotcha like who she had kovat
like why would she fight on the plane
but Trump in the most famous moment
mm-hmm was like walking up in the to the
White House that's at the helicopter
noise and then they were like Trump
what's going on with this deal with
Saudi Arabia and he goes it's gonna be
really great they're gonna give us so
much money great for the economy we're
selling lots of weapons our weapons
manufacturers love it and you know we
want this deal and then all of the
anti-war progressives their jaws just
hit the floor like did you just say what
do you think just admit that the US
economy is bolstered by these war
manufacturers sending weapons in the
Middle East Trump didn't care he's like
yep and he said he was like you know we
got to make sure we get this deal
otherwise you know Russia or China will
get it and they're gonna get it's gonna
be great for their economies but we want
this deal yeah that annoys me the the
amount of people that love to to make
fun of him for this kind of stuff you
know but they're sitting on their phones
they're sitting on the computers they're
sitting enjoying the fruits of the
factories that don't have any
environmental regulations at all on the
other side of the planet destroying the
planet that they're fighting for right
on their phones they're like oh I can I
could go on my phone and complain about
the environment when they're on the
phone built
you know from on the other side of the
planet so Batman arrives me not every
time that there's that comic often
reference because whenever you bring
this up they're like who I I can you
know it that it's a peasant saying we
should improve society right right and a
guy pops out of the well saying yet you
live in society
this is them justifying a fact here's
what they really think I should be
allowed to have a cell phone but you
should not you know that's what they're
saying
boom listen I'm gonna complain about
horrifying authoritarianism and child
slave labor
now I understand all the things I own
are made by that but I'm more effective
this way it's you who shouldn't have it
this is the mistake made by all of these
people it is the false promise used over
and over again throughout history it is
the seventy-two virgins in heaven it is
the one we enact socialism you're gonna
have everything that health care you
always wanted yup
you'll get that you'll finally have a
voice we you see that man over there
with that coffee that golden toilet in
his massive skyscraper know you in New
York you should have that two four four
no work at all agree well you don't have
to work at all that's what they want
they don't want to have to work at all
and isn't it funny that these people who
are protesting I mean it's it's a shame
but right now they have no jobs and
they're protesting to fight for reap
look this is it's very very simple has
nothing to do with the individual and
into a certain degree if people do not
have they will demand because humans
will fight to survive yep this is why
some people theorize revolutions
occurred in the Middle East during the
Arab Spring because of a lack of food
they don't care how they get it they're
gonna demand it and it doesn't matter if
it makes sense so when you have a bunch
of people who have lost their jobs
they're gonna go out and protest for
things like Marxism or communism or
whatever because they're literally like
I don't got food I don't know how to get
food if this is the only thing I can do
I'm gonna go do it not realizing if you
go out and demand stuff for nothing from
someone else you're just stealing you
just you just ask me how to steal for
you that's true now look I get it all of
a sudden every libertarian is popping up
saying did Tim just admit taxation it's
that to a certain extent sure but the
difference between everyone pitching in
to some kind of you know community
fund yeah to run the to fix the roads to
fix and you don't the electricity and
everything like there's a lot that the
taxes go into unfortunately war but it's
true you don't like that system as a
conversation and we've entered out have
a conversation were like work get a job
in government and start striving towards
making the changes looking but here's
what happening a discussion about
whether or not we should all have to
pitch in to support roads and
infrastructure and security know is one
thing they have a large group people
demanding that they produce nothing and
deserve everything he's something
entirely different agreed but completely
they've found a way in and it's black
lives matter they're using that name
because they know you can't criticize
them you like look at men have you seen
the race there was at f1 I think the
race car drivers like half of them Neil
than half of them stood yeah but they
all wore the same shirt or there was
that soccer player woman who refused to
kneel and everyone's cheering for and
when she still wore the shirt because
there's a font like there's the the
companies have straight-up said they
will cut you off unless you unless
you're in line with what we say you know
the intersectional ISM is the new
religion and you must bow or else that's
why I'm pretty sure we're gonna get
banned at some point I'm not even
kidding
smash that like button I can't I can't
imagine we make it to November I don't
know yeah to be fair they did romana
ties people like count dank EULA yeah
you know so he got his channel back
that's that's that's that's good news
many commentators got their channels
back so that's good news thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you